traffic is building rapidly downtown as
citizens rush to get home stay safe
sweetie stay safe
if you're not purging we advise you to
get off the streets it'll soon be a war
up there
this is the commencement of the annual
purge
at the siren all crime including murder
will be legal
all emergency services will be suspended
you know how dangerous it is this won't
bring him back it won't make you feel
any better
don't do this it's late you need to
leave
your government thanks you for your
participation
it's unwritten purge rules
we don't save lives
what is this tonight we take lives we
can't have any interference just drive
just try it stick to the plan we can't
have heroes
no heroes
thank you follow me
the only way we stay alive is if we stay
together
you shouldn't be out here keep moving
and stay quiet
why haven't you just killed us already
oh my god
this is a superb lot fresh off the
streets this is the last purge of the
evening the bidding will start at 200
000.
purges
please suit up
we'll see you shortly on the hunting
grounds
we're gonna have people in front of us
we're gonna have people behind us don't
stop don't look back
run for your life
people like us we don't survive tonight
they're coming
just remember all the good the perch
does
announcing the commencement of the
annual purge
all crime including murder will be legal
your government thanks you for your
participation
just remember